on this episode we talk ID law and what
I do with a thousand dollars and a
shitload of homies decided to join us
show them tear up show them show them
and over here show them pretty intro
yeah over there
you ask questions and I answer them
this is the askgaryvee shut up
you
everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk in the
summers of 97 of the askgaryvee show
people day in new york city i was
dominant in basketball this morning i
just wanted to start with that I really
had a really good day you don't suck
city rock is that we were filming but we
have a stationary feelings I'm not sure
what we caught but Ronnie that many
baskets I'm sure that some of them would
would show up really excited 97 getting
very close to episode 100 Steve came and
so a lot of people in the room after
Mike Mike is here I mean this is a
Andrews rarely here let's you know yeah
I mean this is Zach hasn't been here in
a long time I still work here
excited Steve came in to just you know
tell me a bunch of things about Monday's
episode 100 and then I said you know
just stay and tell them but I'm
remembering things
ptoo pool bar at the gans award that's
right 4:00 p.m. opening the doors for 30
shark starting time another one that we
don't want to tell them it is a 21 and
older venue which means about I need a
lot of people's hearts I collective
hearts were just broken I feel like
there's like some college kids getting
into some road trips that I really
screwed up but he was my curveball as I
told you I've got to be in and out there
but I am going to a Mets game with a
friend and business associates so I have
to go do that but I you know baseball is
boring enough that I can see myself
leaving in the fourth fifth or sixth
inning and coming back in the city using
my Twitter account and go Krita hashtag
you know and and meet a bunch of people
somewhere I'm 80% into that who knows I
could get tired which happens once in a
blue moon baby I just want to go home so
I don't wanna give promises but I love
the idea of you guys all being together
and and of course I want to be there if
I can especially there's so many of your
schlepping so super excited getting this
venue holds about 200th the RSVP thing
is all screwed up because the same six
more but it's not really that so I think
we should be fine so keep it that first
people in I guess at some level then if
you're coming from a far away place
leave a comment
or or in facebook or youtube so I I kind
of feel like if you I'm gonna say this
if you were coming from more than 90
minutes away I'm gonna make sure you get
in I feel like we'll be okay it doesn't
seem like it's gonna be that many people
doing that so there's that that's all
the housecleaning that I can think of
for that and India let's get into the
show
Evan asks do you distinguish between
idea people and doers is there value in
someone with great ideas who needs
others to execute you know I think that
one of the things that I've found at
home in a hundred episodes here is how
much pride I have in being a
practitioner how much I am how much I
respect practicality like how much ideas
are shipped in executions the game
that's one of my favorite quotes right
so but it's interesting this quote this
question as it rolled off of India's
tongue made me realize you know truth is
there is value in it you know what
here's a good way to put it
one of the reasons I think I found ideas
are [ __ ] and executions the game is
because I think the majority of people
that spend a lot of time watching me
aren't at a place where they can afford
the luxury of ideas silent pause for
profoundness let me explain ideas are
great ideas are you know you can really
refer you know as you know I like being
a contradiction ideas are a game right
ideas are a seed you know but so many
people don't have the luxury of being
able to afford the ability to have those
ideas for a long time I didn't have the
luxury of building a company that had
great video people who could come with
me and take my garage sales show and now
I do and I can't wait so pumped we have
to find a town sale that's where all the
action is anyway so I think there is a
place for idea people in India and
vaynernation I think it is it's a range
of people are excited I think that you
have to have the luxury of those people
I think the reason I'm hedging here is
I'm scared so many of your like see he
said idea people get I'm an idea person
and you know you know you can't be you
can't be
you've got to be in the right setting to
get the right value of ideas which is a
huge company that can afford R&D
research and development you know that
kind of thing you just got really lucky
that your partner is so goddamn
practical that he or she respects your
idea skills and wants them but it is a
really weird situation for ideas to to
be valuable in its execution form
especially for the bar majority of the
vaynernation
Albie asks you say you don't consume
much media but isn't it kind of
necessary in order to put out relevant
current content Albie knows it's true
that the man feeling really good about
this show some new kind of topic stuff
like India's hacking India needs new
articles so she's impressive you guys
doing here all plants obviously a great
question the reason I think I produce
such relevant good content is because
I'm listening to my community and that
is my consumption of media so I don't
listen to other thought leaders I don't
watch other shows I don't MA this is my
relaxation right like I don't need
things to unwind
I'm always unwinding even though it
doesn't seem so and so
to me I think the reason on the people
to produce good content is I'm listening
look at the content of the show
you know don't have to do much just
gotta answer goddamn question right like
like like giving people value by
listening and so when I said something
the other day that really makes sense if
you ever get a chance to jam with me or
this is something interesting for you
guys to hear when you know what
somebody's asked so I cut people off
constantly right as you guys all can
attest to because if I and I have good
intuition you know very often like very
often I already know what you're about
to say and I'd much rather us move on to
the next part of execution than giving
you the extra 13 seconds to finish your
[ __ ] sentence so people don't think I
listen but all I do is listen and so I
think the reason I produce good content
is I'm watching do you know how many of
you want watching of what you're
tweeting about when it doesn't have to
do with me when you're putting out
places why do you think I get so pissed
at all of you right because you all say
yeah Gary's right about this and none of
you were doing it do you know a few of
you were actually listening do you know
how many of you that have watched all 97
of these episodes still still aren't
putting in that work aren't executing
properly on that platform aren't playing
the long game are you cutting shortcuts
are putting in the time having tested
dark posts like not playing enough like
do you know how many do that Benjamin
asks i mustache you a question what's
your opinion on brands building social
campaigns around consumers taking
selfies
hashtag mug moustache you know this is
kind of I love your picture so I don't
kiss you you know this is an interesting
question meaning it's not an easy answer
what do I think I think of course like
selfie culture was real it's important I
think it's a noisy space I often when I
go to brainstorms think selfies right
away because it's like it's so in
culture I think it's not a white space I
think that too many brands are doing
things with selfies too many people are
doing things with selfies too many
smarter so like I've already think it's
kind of like I don't call it a help the
shark but like you know it's fine by the
way the ironic thing about making the
statement if you ask me what's one of
the most likely categories of the break
out marketing hit in the next year I
would say South East even with the
answer I just told you meaning for me
it's it's the reason I'd was tough on
the question is like that was literally
asking me like what do you think about
oxygen like II think it's important yes
like what do we think of course yes like
it's a mundane answer it's like yeah I
think it's cool I think it's not cool
meaning they're doing it
somebody could even have a breakout in
if they come up with some clever version
of theirs I don't think it's that
interesting
Amanda asks I just watched episode 96
and you went off on IP I'm an IP lawyer
starting out what is the future and
where does IP fit listen
IP is real by the way I believe in
pensions but pendulums right so I'm very
down on IP I think I should not be
spending that much time on it but I
actually thinks like 12 15 20 30 years
40 years from now as I think more
entrepreneurs of this generation don't
think about it that it will become a
white space and that like they'll be an
opportunity a lot of money in it because
it's still law right you know what I
I think IP and patents fall into the
category of building the biggest
building in town by tearing everybody
else's building these I met this guy he
was like so proud of his lives I think
putting on all these patents and one day
somebody's gonna do something I'm gonna
get him like [ __ ] you and he was like so
taken aback because we're like introduce
my good friends I'm so pissed I didn't
feel I hate that now IP like you know I
think it's important like if you draw a
Mickey Mouse you look don't want other
people like I get it like I I think
there's a place for it but I also the
supply and demand of amazing creative or
ideas or whatever else can be categories
RP is in a very different place too
because everything can see that they
have light now right like you don't have
to work at a Disney or a fox or a media
company or like be an amazing scientist
like and working at GE like and the
Kickstarter has created everybody like
it's just that we're living in this
incredible it's not the police that it
intuitively feels like the right place
to play in right now because the supply
and demand alternatives of the
marketplace dictate a behavior two
minutes a little different now that
being said back to you being an IP
lawyer I think what you should figure
out where all your upside professionally
is is can you become a tastemaker a
forward thinker can you figure out no
mask
now can you figure out a version of
becoming the IP lawyer 2.0 like what's
the future of IP question of the day
Andrew asks it we've got some night
Rangers or the Capitals
got which means nothing to 99 you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
hell yeah that'd be super cool I'm super
pumped right now I may need you me the
show we called the trash talk and I come
back you know I just it was so funny I
thought I just thought this Michael
Jordan Jersey for $2 and I eat Michael
Jordan but I'm gonna do it that's gonna
sell for 40 on the bay you're not you're
still black and white mode I told that
to somebody today on the TV early photos
brilliant white light sorry I'm so
curious as a matter of fact little
comments section can give me feedback on
how you'd like the whole black and white
color transition you caught my reaction
to that right another squared I have
about it obviously it's completely taken
over like yeah